et vous
au commencement une déesse étaient
chargés de protéger la terre
nadine a fait en sorte que le sanctuaire
ne l'attend pas et protéger la cie
athéna était garante de la paix sur
terre elle était aussi la déesse de la
guerre
gardiennes de l' équilibre du monde en
fait mademoiselle saori athéna civ
elle fait cacher des forces du mal
sauvez vous
pour sa protection
elle s'entoure à de valeureux guerriers
placée sous le signe de constellation
les chevaliers du zodiaque
pour sauver leur ds d'une terrible
conspiration ils devront traverser le
sanctuaire du grand peuple
le moment est venu
et y affronter sa légendaire armée des
douze chevaliers d'or alors vous avez
peur
leur plus grande bataille commence
aujourd'hui
nous devons droite et ses affaires
les chevaliers du zodiaque la légende du
sanctuaire le 25 février au cinéma